einige von ihnen verabschieden oder
ihnen beistehen konnten die einsamkeit
des todes in folge von kogit 19
auch darauf möchte die gedenkfeier heute
hinweisen bundespräsident steinmeier hat
geladen zu einem moment des innehaltens
und krone alltag und das mitten in der
dritten welle
deshalb findet das gedenken auch nur im
kleinsten rahmen statt
die staatsspitze also bundespräsident
die kanzlerin und alle präsidenten der
verfassungsorgane versammeln sich gleich
diejenigen also die politisch in der
verantwortung stehen leben zu schützen
begegnen heute hinterbliebenen von
opfern
seit über einer halben stunde gab es
bereits gelegenheit auch zu gesprächen
in nebenräumen bevor die öffentliche
veranstaltung jetzt gleich beginnt ein
tag der trauer und der anteilnahme im
ganzen land vor allen öffentlichen
gebäuden wehen die fahnen auf halbmast
heute vormittag haben die kirchen zu
einem ökumenischen gottesdienst
eingeladen und die berliner
kaiser-wilhelm-gedächtniskirche dabei
verwies der vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz geocaching darauf dass
ich krankheit sterben und tod in diesem
jahr nicht wegdrücken lassen
sie schneiden tief ein in das leben
vieler menschen
und bei dem gottesdienst auch gepredigt
hat der ratsvorsitzende der
evangelischen kirche heinrich bedford
strohm im tag herr bedford strohm warum
ist so eine gedenkfeier wir heute
wichtig ich glaube die gedenkfeier ist
sehr wichtig und sie kommt auch zur
rechten zeit denn es gibt auch so was
wie öffentliche seelsorge es ist wichtig
dass die ganzen geschichten hinter der
großen zahl die sie eben genannt haben
dass diese geschichten ein gesicht
bekommen dass menschen das was sie
erlebt haben erfahren haben ihre trauer
mit anderen teilen können
und ich glaube es wird ihm guttun wenn
sie wissen ein ganzes land trauert mit
ein ganzes land ist dabei wir reden viel
während der pandemie über instanzen
infektionszahlen maßnahmen reden wir so
wenig dabei über die menschen hinter den
zahlen
ja ich glaube wir haben im vergangenen
jahr tatsächlich zu wenig über diese
menschen geredet
es gibt auch so was wie eine seelische
incident und die seelischen inzidenz
werde dies sind nach oben geschnellt was
macht das virus mit unserer seele
es reicht nicht über die frage zu reden
welche kontakt beschränkungen notwendig
sind welche tourismus der ziele noch
angeflogen werden können
auch die schulschließung das ist alles
wichtig aber es auch sehr wichtig mal
drüber zu reden was dieses virus mit der
seele macht es betrifft jeden und jede
aber wir reden nicht öffentlich darüber
weil es halt so persönlich ist und der
heutige tag ist für mich ein einschnitt
ab heute sollten wir auch über die seele
reden auch öffentlich über die seele
reden es gibt ja jeden tag neue
todeszahlen hat sich denn deutschland
schon an 200 300 tote am tag gewöhnt ich
glaube dass jedenfalls die gefahr
besteht
und wenn man dann sieht wie menschen
demonstrieren gegen beschränkungen gegen
die regeln
und dann sieht wie die zahl der
intensivpatienten immer mehr hochgeht
dann ist es glaube ich sehr wichtig dass
diese zahlen ein gesicht bekommt dass
wir das leiden hinter den zahlen sehen
und deswegen auch wissen
warum wir uns an diese kontakt
beschränkungen einhalten wir reden
gleich weiter sie haben es gesagt die
opfer sollen heute ein gesicht und eine
stimme bekommen die angehörigen im
mittelpunkt stehen die erste der
hinterbliebenen die heute sprechen wird
ist anita schädel
hier sehen sie wie sie gerade schon im
konzerthaus sie hat vergangen april
ihren mann verloren und stabile basler
hat sie zu hause in passau besucht sie
hatten noch so viel vor
anita scheele und jemand hannes
zwölf jahre sind sie eng verbunden ein
spätes unendliches glück so die 56
jährige
mein mann war meine große liebe meines
lebens waren mein traum und mein ein und
alles und wir haben nie darüber
nachgedacht dass wir uns dass wir uns
verlieren könnten
im april 2020 infizieren sie sich mit
dem corona virus wohnt wie anita schädel
weiß es nicht
beiden geht es schlecht sie sind zu
hause in quarantäne
und dann ging es von einem tag zum
wandern wirklich absolut rapide bergab
mann wurde kurz auf mich war nicht mehr
in der lage das plätze verlassen
anitas schädel alarmierte notarzt hier
man selbst mediziner wird sofort in die
klinik transportiert sie darf ihn nicht
begleiten habe ich am abend und habe
noch einige küsten haben gesagt dass ich
in zwiebeln und ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass das letzte mal war dass ich das
sage sie bleibt zurück allein voller
sorge und ungewissheit um ihn
mein mann hat mich dann von der intensiv
angerufen hat mir erklärt er wird jetzt
künstlich ins koma versetzt wird beatmet
war aber sehr positiv und hat mir auch
noch gesagt dass ich ihn bald wieder
aufholen kann
und das waren sie ein letztes gespräch
anita schädel wartet stunden tage lang
einmal am tag ein telefonat mit den
ärzten zu setzen zeiten das ist alles
jeden tag habe ich gefragt gebettelt die
ob ich zum dorf dann am 14 april 2020
meldet sich die klinik bei ihr 1235 kam
der anruf dass es mein mann dass es ganz
ganz ernstes der 59-jährige ist nicht
mehr zu retten hannes schedel stirbt
nach acht tagen kampf ums überleben
das virus war stärker angehen zu lassen
ohne abschied nehmen zu können
stürzt seine frau anita in tiefe trauer
dass ich nichts tun konnte was ich auch
nicht beiden wurde das hat mich so
beschäftigt dass er einfach so alleine
war
ich hätte mir so gewünscht dass ich mal
ein kleines zeichen also meine hand
drücken hätte können
um nach dem tod ihres mannes nicht in
einsamkeit zu ertrinken wie anita sagt
taste sie sich vorsichtig ins leben
zurück treffe vertraute von früh ein weg
zu sehen was kann ich für mich tun der
wird sie finden und es ist für mich auch
ein weg darüber jetzt zu sprechen und
das und eben auch nur stimmen ein
gesicht zu geben denn corona können uns
alle treffen und das leiden dass diese
krankheit anrichten kann sei nur schwer
zu ertragen wenn man wird mir ein leben
lang viel thema herr bedford strohm die
hinterbliebenen müssen mit dem verlust
leben kann so eine gedenkveranstaltung
wie heute bei der verarbeitung helfen
ich glaube schon das ist ja eine sehr
berührende geschichte und ich habe
gestern angehörige getroffenen frau
schädel war auch dabei und ich habe die
geschichten gehört das geht einem sehr
nahe und was mich aber auch sehr berührt
hat ist zu spüren wie das teilen der
persönlichen der je eigenen geschichte
wechselseitig wie das kraft gegeben hat
und deswegen wünsche ich mir dass
überall in deutschland menschen
zusammenkommen können in gruppen die
diese erfahrung gemacht haben und
einander stärken können und dass wir
alle jetzt diese geschichten hören dass
sie öffentlich werden ist wichtig und
ich bin dankbar dafür dass sie bereit
sind das zu teilen
es soll ja heute nicht nur um die
verstorbenen durch corona gehen sondern
auch unter den bedingungen der pandemie
also viele konnten ihren angehörigen in
den letzten minuten nicht beistehen sich
nicht mehr verabschieden wie belastend
ist denn so eine situation seine trauer
ohne abschied
das ist sehr belastend denn wenn du
diesen abschied nicht vollziehen kannst
abschied heißt der beziehung auf dauer
stellen und wenn du dir das geraubt wird
dann ist es ganz schwer damit zurecht zu
kommen wo es braucht lange bis man
innerlich den frieden
damit findet dass das vollendet werden
wird ich sage jetzt religiös von gott
vollendet werden wird was wir menschen
nicht vollenden können
vielen dank herr bedford strohm und
damit als auch für uns der moment
gekommen innezuhalten die zentrale
gedenkfeier für die verstorbenen in der
korona pandemie beginnt gleich ich gebe
ab ins konzerthaus an
damen marktes kommentiert michael
bartenbach
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach dem kanon in d dur von johann
pachelbel folgt nur die gedenkansprache
von bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier
wem kann ich klagen der mit mir fühlt
wem kann ich sagen was in mir wühlt
fragen mit denen der schriftsteller
erich mühsam in stunden von bitterkeit
und verzweiflung gerungen hat fragen die
viele menschen heute umtreiben
liebe angehörige und trauernde verehrte
repräsentanten unseres staates förderer
drei jahren des diplomatischen kurs
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger vor
mehr als einem jahr ist die pandemie
über uns hereingebrochen sie hat tiefe
wunden geschlagen und auf schreckliche
weise lücken geritten gerissen in
unserem land in europa in der ganzen
welt und wir wissen sie ist immer noch
nicht vorbei wir sind eher müde von der
last der pandemie und wund gerieben im
streit um den richtigen weg
auch deshalb auch deshalb brauchen wir
einen moment des innehaltens ein moment
jenseits der tagespolitik einen moment
der uns gemeinsam einen blick auf die
menschliche tragödie der pandemie
erlaubt wir wollen und wir müssen der
menschen gedenken die seit dem beginn
der pandemie gestorben sind
wir wollen heute als gesellschaft derer
gedenken die in dieser dunklen zeit
einen einsamen und oft qualvollen tod
gestorben sind
80.000 menschen sind dem virus in
unserem land bisher zum opfer gefallen
mehr als drei millionen sind es weltweit
tag für tag sterben weitere an den
folgen der infektion auch in dieser
stunde
ringen menschen auf den
intensivstationen mit dem tod
aber nicht nur derjenigen die an cholera
gestorben sind gedenken wir viele andere
ohne mit dem virus infiziert zu sein
waren unter den bedingungen der pandemie
allein sind ohne beistand und abschied
verstorben
seit dem beginn der katastrophe blicken
wir täglich wie gebannt auf
infektionsraten und todeszahlen
verfolgen kurvenverläufe vergleichen und
bewerten das ist verständlich aber mein
eindruck ist dass wir uns als
gesellschaft nicht oft genug bewusst
machen dass hinter all den zahlen
schicksale menschen stehen ihr leiden
und ihr sterben sind in der
öffentlichkeit oft unsichtbar geblieben
eine gesellschaft die dieses leid
verdrängt wird als ganzes schaden nehmen
also schauen wir heute nicht auf zahlen
und statistiken sondern auf die menschen
die von uns gegangen sind frauen und
männer aus allen regionen unseres landes
hochbetagte ältere und jüngere erinnern
an ihre namen gesichter und geschichten
und so unterschiedlich sie waren und
gelebt haben sie alle fehlen
sie fehlen in ihren familien und
freundeskreisen in der nachbarschaft im
kreis der kollegen in unserer
gesellschaft und sie kommen nicht zurück
aber sie bleiben in unserer erinnerung
wir vergessen sie nicht wir gedenken
heute auch der menschen die seit dem
beginn dieser globalen katastrophe in
europa und auf der ganzen welt gestorben
sind
die trauer verbindet uns über grenzen
hinweg und die erfahrung des geteilten
lights bestärkt uns auch gemeinsam zu
handeln
in europa und weltweit liebe landsleute
vergessen wir nicht unter welchen
besonderen bedingungen menschen in
dieser zeit bei uns gestorben sind
sterben in der pandemie das war und das
ist oft ein sterben ohne beistand ohne
abschied manchmal durften selbst
angehörige ihre nächsten in
krankenhäusern pflegeheimen hospizen
nicht besuchen
viele menschen sind verstorben ohne dass
ihre verwandten und freunde sich von
ihnen verabschieden könnten
wir denken an alle die im moment ihres
todes keine vertraute stimme hören kein
vertrautes gesicht sehen konnten
sie sterben mussten ohne ein letztes
zärtliches wort einen letzten
liebevollen blick einen letzten
händedruck das zu wissen
zerreißt uns das herz es macht uns
unendlich traurig wir denken heute auch
an die ärztinnen und ärzte die
pflegerinnen und pfleger die in dieser
zeit tag und nacht um jedes leben
kämpfen oft bis zur völligen erschöpfung
und nicht selten darüber hinaus wir
denken an all jene die in krankenhäusern
pflegeheimen in der seelsorge und den
hospizen bis zuletzt für sterbende da
sind die versucht haben ihnen trotz
allem einen abschied in würde zu
ermöglichen
wir sind dankbar für ihre fürsorge für
ihre nächstenliebe sie alle riskieren
ihre gesundheit um für andere da zu sein
nicht wenige haben sich während sie
ihren beruf ausübten selbst mit dem
virus angesteckt einige sind gestorben
auch ihnen wollen wir heute ehre
erweisen wir verneigen uns mit respekt
vor ihrem selbstlosen engagement
wir gedenken heute der toten und wir
wenden uns zugleich den lebenden zu die
um sie trauern in dem anteil am leid der
hinterbliebenen die in dieser
schwierigen zeit halt und trost suchen
die sich einsam fühlen in ihrer trauer
und oft nicht wissen wie es weitergehen
soll
viele von ihnen liebe mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger haben in den vergangenen
monaten um angehörige gedankt gezittert
und geweint
manche konnten ihre nächsten gehalt aus
den kliniken abholen aber viele haben
vor verschlossenen krankenhaus türen
gestanden und gefleht noch einmal zu
ihrer frau oder ihrem mann gelassen zu
werden
zu ihrer mutter ihrem vater ihre tochter
ihren sohn
es gibt keine worte für ihren schmerz
aber wir hören ihre klage
wir verstehen ihre bitterkeit viele von
ihnen haben mir geschrieben mit manchen
habe ich sprechen können sie haben mir
von ihrer verzweiflung berichtet ich
weiß dass einige sich unendlich quälen
weil sie sterbenden angehörigen auf dem
letzten weg nicht beistehen können dass
sie sich sogar vorwerfen ihre liebsten
im stich gelassen zu haben
für manche wiegt der verlust doppelt
schwer weil ihnen ein letzter blick auf
den verstorbenen eine letzte berührung
verwehrt geblieben ist
andere belastete schwer dass sie ihre
angehörigen nicht so bestatten konnten
wie sie und vor allem der verstorbene
sich das gewünscht hätten
viele sind überfordert und verzweifelt
weil sie in der stunde größter trauer
dennoch der schmerz der todesnachricht
einen lähmt sie ausgerechnet dann
verwandten freunden bekannten die
teilnahme an der trauerfeier versagen
müssen
rituale des trauerns geben halt spenden
trost stiften sinn in der zeit der
pandemie konnten diese rituale oft nicht
wie gewohnt oder aber gar nicht
stattfinden viele trauernde haben
bestattungen die nur im allerkleinsten
kreis stattfinden konnten
als trostlos empfunden
sie haben die gemeinschaftliche trauer
vermisst die verabschiedung am offenen
grab sie haben andere menschen vermisst
jemanden der sie in den arm nimmt und
mit ihnen weit
viele trauernde treibt die befürchtung
um dass ohne dieses gemeinsam erinnern
ihre toten sang und klanglos
verschwinden dass sie nicht weiterleben
im gedächtnis der familien des
freundeskreises oder der nachbarschaft
sie sehnen sich danach die verstorbenen
mit ihrer ganzen lebensgeschichte in der
gemeinschaft aufgehoben zu wissen
möge der heutige tag allen trauernden
anlass geben über den verlust sprechen
zu können
einige wenige hinterbliebene sind heute
bei uns hirn soll
wir wollen ihre stimmen hören
stellvertretend für die vielen anderen
die in dieser zeit um ihre angehörigen
trauern
auch an vielen anderen orten unseres
landes gedenken menschen heute der
verstorbenen neben anteil am schicksal
der hinterbliebenen
sie zünden kerzen an legen blumen nieder
pflanzen bäume lassen an gedenkt stellen
ein gedicht oder ein gebet zurück gerade
jetzt brauchen wir solche orte an denen
wir mit kleinen gesten zeigen können
wir sind füreinander da wir sind uns
nahe auch wenn wir immer noch abstand
halten müssen
heute wollen wir allen trauernden unser
mitgefühl ausdrücken überall in unserem
land wir wollen ihnen sagen ihr seid
nicht allein
mit eurem leid nicht allein in eurer
trauer wir heute einen moment innehalten
dann wird uns bewusst dass das virus
unsere gesellschaft tief erschüttert und
verwundet hat als wir uns das im alltag
eingestehen
es wird bewusst wie schwer uns das alle
trifft wir alle spüren sorge spüren
ungewissheit wie alle leiden unter den
beschränkungen die wir uns auferlegen
mussten und weiß weiter auferlegen
müssen um die pandemie einzudämmen weil
wir wissen auch längst das virus
gefährdet nicht alle gleich und die
beschränkungen setzen nicht allen gleich
stürzen
deshalb denken wir heute besonders an
diejenigen die diese krise besonders
hart getroffen hat an die menschen die
an den spätfolgen einer infektion leiden
an jene die seelisch krank geworden sind
vor einsamkeit und enge an menschen die
gewalt erlitten haben bedenken an jene
die in wirtschaftliche not geraten sind
und um ihre existenz bangen an die
kinder die auf schule und freunde
verzichten müssen an junge menschen die
ausgerechnet in ihrem start ins leben
ausgebremst sind sie alle tragen eine
außerordentliche last ich übersehen
nicht liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
neben der trauer gibt es bei manchen
auch verbitterung und wut viele die mir
geschrieben haben fragen sich ob
bestimmte einschränkungen die
beschlossen wurden um die pandemie
einzudämmen
zu viel freiheit genommen haben sie
fragen sicher bei dem versuch menschen
lebend zu retten
die menschlichkeit manchmal auf der
strecke geblieben ist ich verstehe die
fragen
ich verstehe die verbitterung und ja es
stimmt wir haben menschen einsamkeit
zugemutet um andere vor krankheit oder
tod zu schützen
wir haben unser leben einschränken
müssen um leben zu retten
das ist ein konflikt aus dem es keinen
widerspruchsfreien ausweg gibt
ich weiß dass einschränkungen die in der
ausnahmesituation der pandemie notwendig
sind unbeabsichtigt auch leid und not
verursacht haben das ist die bittere
wahrheit aber ich weiß auch die politik
musste schwierige manchmal tragische
entscheidungen treffen um eine noch
größere katastrophe zu verhindern
wir alle auch die politik haben lernen
müssen
am fortschritte gemacht und wo es fehler
und versäumnisse gab da müssen und
werden wir das aufarbeiten aber nicht an
diesem tag nicht heute meine bitte ist
heute sprechen wir über schmerz und leid
und wut aber verlieren wir uns nicht in
schuldzuweisungen im blick zurück
sondern sammeln wir noch einmal die
kraft für den weg nach vorn den weg
heraus aus der pandemie den wir gehen
wollen und gehen werden wenn wir ihn
gemeinsam gehen lassen wir nicht zu dass
die pandemie die uns schon als menschen
auf abstand zwingt uns auch noch als
gesellschaft auseinander treibt
liebe landsleute
die pandemie erinnert uns an etwas das
wir allzu gern verdrängen dass wir
verlässliche unsterbliche wesen sind
nicht alles lässt sich planen berechnen
absichern und beherrschen
wir haben nicht alles im griff so gar
nicht den tod
auch wenn die medizin immer mehr
krankheiten heilen immer mehr leben
retten kann die alle stehen dem tod
letztlich ohnmächtig und ratlos
gegenüber und es fällt uns schwer das
hinzunehmen
die pandemie lehrt uns demut gegenüber
dem verfügbaren diese erfahrung mag eine
große enttäuschung sein
eine kränkung eine so sehr auf
selbstoptimierung gerichteten zeitgeist
aber ich glaube dass diese erfahrung
auch heilsam sein können im angesicht
von krankheit und tod
fragen wir uns was im leben wirklich
wichtig ist und wir erkennen was zählt
es nicht nur die sorge um das eigene
wohlergehen sondern auch die sorge um
das leben und die gesundheit anderer vom
ersten tag dieser pandemie an haben wir
das miteinander erfahren vom ersten tag
an sahen wir wie viel gemeinsinn wie
viel mitgefühl in dieser gesellschaft
stecken in allen teilen unseres landes
waren menschen füreinander da und sind
es immer noch viele setzen sich in ihrem
beruf im ehrenamt in der nachbarschaft
in der familie
unermüdlich für jene ein die die krise
mit voller wucht getroffen hat diese
mitmenschlichkeit
sie ist ein lichtblick in dunkler zeit
und ich glaube
das ist die existenzielle die bleibende
erfahrung der pandemie wenn es hart auf
hart kommt sind wir auf andere
angewiesen und andere auf uns diese
lehre werden wir mit uns tragen sie wird
uns prägen jeden und jede und ich glaube
sie kann auch die gesellschaft prägen in
der wir leben werden die zukunft in die
wir aufbrechen
wir werben von dieser pandemie zeit
gezeichnet sein aber auch angewachsen
wir werden die pandemie hinter uns
lassen
wir werden aufatmen und wieder freier
leben und wir sind auf dem weg dorthin
in rekordzeit haben wissenschaftler
impfstoffe entwickelt und tag für tag
erreichen mehr menschen durch die
impfung das rettende ufer
wir werden uns als menschen wieder nahe
sein und als gesellschaft vereint dass
das möglich ist dass wir einander
verbunden sind auch mitten in der
pandemie
das spüren wir gerade heute in dieser
stunde in der wir gemeinsam inne halten
wir sehen die wunden die die pandemie
geschlagen hat wir gedenken der
verstorbenen und wir fühlen mit den
lebenden die um sie trauern bleiben wir
beieinander und geben wir acht
aufeinander
das war die gedenkrede dessen und des
präsidenten oder schwein beim gedanken
an die verstorbenen der bundespräsident
wird jetzt eine kerze an der
gedenkstelle in der mitte des saals
aufstellen
begleitet wird er dabei von michael
mengel aus essen ihre 23 jährige tochter
annalena starb vor einem jahr mit 19
nachdem das ärzte team auf der
intensivstation elf tage lang um ihr
leben gekämpft hatte der bundespräsident
hatte michaela menge bereits im märz ins
schloss bellevue empfangen
in seiner rede rief er dazu auf dass wir
uns jetzt nicht in schuldzuweisungen
verlieren sollten nicht im blick zurück
sondern dass wir noch einmal kraft
sammeln sollen für den weg nach vorn
dass diese mitmenschlichkeit die viel
erfahren haben in der pandemie ein
lichtblick in dunkler zeit sein kann
wir hören nun den ersten satz von
johannes brahms ein deutsches requiem
trauer und trost
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es spricht nun in dieser schädel aus
passau deren mann hannes schedel vor
einem jahr in komik 19 verstorben ist
was machst du denn da anita meine frau
halt das würde man jetzt sagen er würde
den kopf leicht schräg legen lächeln um
mich schließlich ein wenig stolz in den
arm nehmen
ohne ihn würde ich heute nicht hier sein
mein mann ist letztes jahr am 14 april
an komik 19 gestorben
mit 59 jahren aber arzt und klinik
betreiber hat sich mit selbstverständnis
hoher professionalität und
uneingeschränkter leidenschaft für die
patienten und mitarbeiter eingesetzt
auch ich habe mein ganzes berufsleben im
gesundheitswesen gearbeitet und schon
vor unserer heirat hat er mich in seine
klinik geholt
am 21 märz bei carola bei uns in der
klinik angekommen
wir mussten schließen die patienten nach
hause und die mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit
schicken
eine nie da gewesene situation in der
60-jährigen geschichte der klinik
wir waren hilflos und doch guter dinge
dass es bald weiter gehen würde
vor einem jahr wusste man ja kaum etwas
über das wir dass es da heute kein
wochenende dann zeigte man symptome
auch ich hatte fieber aber ihm geht es
ging es von tag zu tag schlechter
am 6 april rief ich schließlich der
notarzt dann brachte der krankenwagen
meinem mann ins klinikum
ich durfte nicht mitfahren gegen korona
von der intensivstation liefern mich
noch einmal an ich werde jetzt
künstliche koma versetzt und beatmet
nach dir keine sorgen ich bin in den
besten händen
du kannst mich bald wieder abholen ich
freue mich auf dich das war unser
letztes gespräch acht tage bangen warten
auf den täglichen anrufe der behandelten
ärzte hoffen auf ein wunder beten dass
die schlimmsten befürchtungen nicht wahr
werden
sie wurden war am 14 april dürfte ich zu
meinem mann auf die intensivstation
als feststand dass man medizinisch
nichts mehr machen konnte bis heute
begleiten mich die bilder von dem
einsamen langen klinik flur von dem
blinkenden und päpsten den geräten den
schläuchen maschinen und mittendrin mein
hannes gezeichnet vom virus ich konnte
nur noch seine hand drücken dass mir
wenigstens das ermöglicht wurde
dafür bin ich dem klinikum dankbar mein
mann hat sein leben verloren
ich bin ins nichts gefallen aber ich
habe noch ein leben es ist ganz anders
als vorher
es war nicht meine entscheidung aber
mein mann würde wir erwarten dass ich
den wert des lebens wieder erkennen
doch wie ich darf den zig tausenden
hinterbliebenen eine stimme geben die
auch einen geliebten menschen und das
virus verloren haben
die allein gelassen sind mit ihrer
trauer weil wegen der pandemie selbst
trösten rituale unmöglich sind
so schlimm das alles ist darf man heute
ein jahr nach der ersten welle nicht
vergessen es gibt mittlerweile
impfstoffe die schwere verläufe
verhindern
die ältere generation ist in der regel
durch kämpft das reicht aber nicht die
inzidenz steigt seit wochen wieder an
die man auch sterben menschen in
deutschland an caron so viele als würde
jede woche ein flugzeug abstürzen
aber wir haben eben der korona
schutzimpfung tests nach medikamenten
wird geforscht
mittlerweile hat man erfahrungswerte und
weiß wie richtig und wichtig die
einhaltung der hygiene regel ist auch
wenn die krone müdigkeit nach zwölf
monaten pandemie zunimmt
ich appelliere an sie alle halten sie
durch es kommt auf jeden einzelnen und
mir kann nicht so niemand meinem mann zu
bringen
aber jeder einzelnen die mein schicksal
und das der angehörigen freunde der
80.000 corinna toten in deutschland der
sport bleibt ist es wird
deswegen bleiben sie stark und
zuversichtlich ich versuche es auch zu
sein
auch ein hinter schädel wird jetzt
wieder andere an alle anderen
hinterbliebenen eine kerze an der
gedenkstelle aufstellen
begleitet wird sie dabei von
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
der schädel wurde von ihrem cousin
begleitet jede die hinterbliebenen hat
eine begleitperson mitgebracht um an
diesem tag nicht alleine zu sein
als nächste angehörige hören wir nun den
kauf r wunsch aus ritterhude die ihren
vater net stellt ein wunsch verloren hat
mein vater peter wunsch ist 81 jahre alt
geworden bevor das virus ihm am 23
januar 2021 morgens um 1 uhr das leben
nahm
eine woche nachdem er positiv auf
corinna getestet wurde in den letzten
stunden seines lebens konnten wir nicht
bei ihnen sein da er nach einem
wirbelbruch in einer kurzzeitpflege
einrichtung war die wegen eines corona
ausbruches unter quarantäne stand dank
einer jungen liebevollen pflegerin war
er jedoch nicht allein sie hat sich über
das normale maß hinaus um mein vater
gekümmert und war bis zu seinem letzten
atemzug bei ihm papa wurde am vierten
september 1939 in manisa in der türkei
geboren und wuchs in izmir bei seiner
tante auf
mit mitte 20 entschied er sich als
gastarbeiter nach deutschland zu gehen
in bremen lernte er sehr bald meine
mutter kennen und sie heirateten und
bekam drei töchter
leider weiß ich nicht viel aus seiner
kindheit und jugend in der türkei hat
darüber nicht viel gesprochen aber meine
tochter klarer erzählte mir vor ein paar
tagen dass ihr opa ihr vor einiger zeit
vor schwärmte wie er als kind im meer
mit rosa delfin geschwommen sei zu
seiner enkelin hatte ein ganz besondere
bindung und sagte mir noch vor seinem
tod dass es keine worte für seine liebe
zu ihr gebe
seine familie war für ihn das wichtigste
neben seiner liebe zu seinem heimatland
er hatte bis zuletzt heimweh nach der
türkei jedes jahr in sind wir in den
sommerferien in die türkei in den urlaub
gefahren
hier lebte er jedes mal förmlich auf und
tankte energie eine kindheitserinnerung
meiner älteren schwester serap die
letztes jahr ebenfalls gestorben ist
beschreibt das sehr schön
sie schreibt im sommer urlaub in der
türkei waren mein vater und ich oft
zusammen ganz früh morgens angeln
das war unheimlich schön er hat mir
genau gezeigt wie man köder an die
angemacht und wie man aus wirft oft hat
er mich gelobt wenn ich einen fisch
gefangen
in deutschland hatte ich nie so engen
kontakt zu ihm wie in der türkei
ihr tod hat meine eltern schwer
getroffen
und als ich mein vater das letzte mal
gesehen habe briefe immer wieder ihren
namen aber auch den namen seiner
schwester seiner jüngsten tochter elif
und seiner frau meiner mutter uta
plötzlich hielt er ganz kurz inne und
guckte mich an und sagte es rien
ich liebe dich dann rief er wieder die
namen sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
in dieser schweren zeit haben sie uns
mit ihrer aktion licht fenster unter
planung einer gedenkveranstaltung sehr
viel kraft und trost gegeben
das wird darüber hinaus jetzt hier sein
und meinem vater ein gesicht geben
dürfen rührt und ehrt uns sehr
dafür bedanke ich mich von herzen dies
wird für uns ein wichtiger schritt in
richtung trauerbewältigung sein
das war es den kaufwunsch in die in
begleitung ihrer mutter nach berlin
gekommen ist
mit ihr wird jetzt bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel eine kerze in der mitte
des saals aufstellen
außer den hinterbliebenen und den
vertretern der verfassungsorgane ist
auch michael müller anwesend der
vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dem gremium
das besonders mit der pandemie bekämpfen
bekannt befasst ist außerdem der
apostolische nuntius dr nicola terror
witsch er ist botschafter des vatikans
und damit vertreter des diplomatischen
kurs
aus dem deutschen requiem von johannes
brahms folgt nun der zweite satz schmerz
und zuversicht in einer szenischen
fassung von jochen sandig vorgetragen
vom rundfunkrat berlin unter leitung von
gis lenas die einsamkeit in der pandemie
in der wir abstand voneinander halten
müssen wird sich die darstellung
besonders deutlich
[Musik]
si
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es spricht nun finja wilkens aus
ganderkesee in niedersachsen ihr vater
hans georg wilkins ist letztes jahr an
leukämie verstorben
mein papa hat immer gesagt dass er wie
eine katze sei er habe sieben leben
sieben leben gelebt werden wollen so
gerne hätten wir ihm das geglaubt und
uns gewünscht ist es wahr wird mein name
ist schön ja ich bin 28 jahre alt und
komme aus ganderkesee im landkreis
oldenburg
ich habe im november mein vater verloren
er ist nach zwei monaten krankenhaus
aufenthalt im universitätsklinikum
eppendorf im alter von 53 jahren
verstorben
er ist einer von vielen die während der
korona pandemie nicht an oder mit corona
verstorben sind
er hat den kampf gegen den blutkrebs
verloren die letzten wochen seines
lebens waren nicht so wie wir sie uns
gewünscht hätten
die zeit war so wie mein papa sie nicht
verdient hat wie niemand sie verdient
hat zusammen mit meiner schwester bin
ich auf dem hof unsere eltern
aufgewachsen
unsere eltern haben sich dort zusammen
etwas aufgebaut
sie haben nicht nur schweinezucht
betrieben sondern den hofball zu einem
spiel und spaß auf erweitert auf dem
kinder tiere streicheln konnten und mit
fahrrädern und bobby cars ihre runden
drehen durften in den letzten 15 jahren
haben wir gastronomie in form eines
majors betrieben und gäste mit milch
speisen versorgt und gleichzeitig den
menschen das land auf dem leben ein
wenig näher gebracht
mein papa hat sein ganzes herzblut da
hineingesteckt
alle die auf den hof kamen steckte er
mit seiner positiven art an
er glaubte unerschütterlich an das gute
im menschen neckte die leute gerne und
nutzte konsequent alle die ihm über den
weg liefen
besonders zeichnet die ihnen seine
hilfsbereitschaft aus von seiner
hilfsbereiten ara profitierten nicht nur
freunde familie und kollegen sondern oft
auch fremde menschen die er gerne
unterstützt hat er wollte dafür keine
anerkennung und hat es niemals an die
große glocke
hängt vor etwa einem jahr erkrankte mein
papa plötzlich es ging ihm nicht gut er
hatte zunächst schmerzen in den händen
und den füßen und der hüfte
es dauerte ein paar monate des im juni
letzten jahres die dioden die die
diagnose gestellt wurde eine welt brach
zusammen als familie halten wir immer
zusammen
wir waren überzeugt davon dass mein papa
ist schaffen kann ende september kam
mein papa ins uke wo direkt mit der
therapie begonnen wurde wegen vieler
komplikationen die während der
behandlung auftraten waren wir immer auf
das krankenhauspersonal angewiesen um
überhaupt kontakt per videoanruf zu im
herzustellen was leider nicht mal
täglich der fall war
wir wollten es nicht und doch haben wir
ihn alleine gelassen durch die geltenden
corinna bestimmungen war es uns nicht
anders erlaubt sein zustand wurde
schlechter er wurde ins künstliche koma
gelegt
eine woche voller hoffen und bangen kein
kontakt keinen einblick kein hand halten
oder einfach da sein
es war die hölle für uns wir durften
nicht im krankenhaus anrufen sondern die
behandelnden ärzte haben sich einmal am
tag gemeldet
alle waren wie erstarrt wenn das telefon
klingelte und man auf gute nachrichten
hoffte wir waren als familie genommen
und haben oft nur bruchteile mitbekommen
von dem was uns mitgeteilt wurde der
satz so lange sie nicht zu ihm dürfen
ist noch alles in ordnung wird mir dabei
immer im kopf bleiben
mein papa war immer da er war immer für
uns und auch für andere da und in der
schwersten zeit seines lebens war es uns
nicht möglich für ihn da zu sein
wir fühlen uns als hätten wir ihn im
stich gelassen es fühlt sich nicht fair
an und bedrückt uns nach wie vor
unheimlich
wir verstehen die maßnahmen in
medizinischen einrichtungen gar keine
frage
und wir sind auch dankbar zum abschied
nehmen vor ort gewesen zu sein
aber nur zum wenden der
lebenserhaltenden maßnahmen am
sterbebett sein zu dürfen und vorher in
zwei monaten nicht bei ihm sein zu
können war einfach nur schrecklich
mein papa hat sein leben immer sehr
genossen er war leicht
zufriedenzustellen aber so ein ende hat
er definitiv nicht verdient ich bin froh
dass wir ein fantastisches umfeld haben
freunde familie und kollegen die
versuchen so gut es geht für uns da zu
sein auch und besonders weil es durch
die kontrakt beschränkungen nicht immer
so ganz einfach war und ist sehr
geehrter herr bundespräsident
ich denke ich spreche im namen von
vielen hinterbliebenen die ein ähnliches
schicksal teilen und die letzten wochen
ihrer sterbenden angehörigen nicht
begleiten konnten und durften
ich wünsche mir dass wir diese pandemie
bald in den griff bekommen und damit
niemand mehr so etwas durchmachen muss
jeder mensch hat es verdient in würde zu
sterben und niemanden sollte diesen weg
alleine gehen müssen
mein papa hat immer gesagt dass er wie
eine katze sein
er habe sieben leben sieben leben die
gelebt werden wollen so gerne hätten wir
ihm das geglaubt hat uns gewünscht dass
es wahr wird
das war finja wilkens das schicksal von
ihr und ihrer familie steht
stellvertretend für die vielen menschen
die in der pandemie von ihren liebsten
nicht so abschied nehmen konnten wie sie
sich gewünscht hätten
auch sie wird eine kerze in der mitte
des saals abstellen
sie wird begleitet von
bundesratspräsident reiner haseloff
als letzter der angehörigen spricht nun
der def jacobs aussehen man in rheinland
pfalz seine mutter renate starb im
september letzten jahres drei tage vorm
achtzigsten geburtstag in einem
altenheim
ich möchte ihnen etwas zu meiner mutter
renate jacobs erzählen
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
vielen dank dass mehr raum hierfür geben
meine mutter wurde 1940 in koblenz
geboren und sie verstarb auch dort
letztes jahr im september vier tage vor
ihrem 18 geburtstag
die letzten drei jahre ihres lebens
verbrachte sie in einem seniorenheim
was war meine mutter für ein mensch
meine mutter war eine sehr gesellige und
lebensbejahende frau sie war verheiratet
hatte eine große familie mit vier
kindern und sieben enkelkindern
sie liebte es sich mit freunden zu
treffen und tanzen zu gehen
außerdem liebte sie die natur sie mochte
es draußen zu sein und das auch bei
jedem wetter es verging kein tag an dem
sie nicht in ihrem garten war oder mit
ihrem hund spazieren ging
während ihrer ersten zeit im
seniorenheim hat sie genau diese dinge
auch weiterhin machen können
sie hat trotz ihrer fortschreitenden
demenz erkrankungen sehr gerne an den
wöchentlichen musik und
tanzveranstaltungen teilgenommen sie
mochte es sehr mit ihren
mitbewohnerinnen und mitbewohnern zu
plaudern dabei ein tässchen kaffee zu
trinken und ein leckeres stück kuchen zu
essen
bei besuchen durch ihre kinder und
enkelkinder oder durch ihre freundinnen
führt die ihre spaziergänge immer nach
draußen in den nahegelegenen park durch
den beginn der korona pandemie
veränderte sich der tagesablauf meiner
mutter vollständig besucher konnten
nicht mehr stattfinden
das hauseigene café wurde geschlossen
und die geselligen runden fanden nicht
mehr statt das war für meine mutter eine
enorme einschnitte
aufgrund ihrer demenz erkrankung konnten
wir nicht verständlich machen worum wir
und ihre freundinnen sind nicht mehr
besuchen konnten andere
kommunikationswege waren aufgrund ihrer
erkrankung nicht möglich sie hat sehr
unter der situation gelitten
erst nach etwa drei monaten konnten wir
meine mutter wieder besuchen
ich kann mich noch genau daran erinnern
mein erster besuch nach dieser langen
zeit war mit der banken erwartung
verbunden dass meine mutter mich
vielleicht nicht mehr erkennen würde
glücklicherweise erkannte mich noch und
wir mussten beide vor freude über das
gemeinsame wiedersehen beinen in der
nächsten zeit konnten die besucher
abgesehen von den üblichen maßnahmen
fast wieder in der gewohnten form
stattfinden
besonders berührend fand ich hier eine
begebenheit als ich mit meiner tochter
im seniorenheim zu besuch war
meine tochter hatte ihre oma mirabellen
mitgebracht die sie ihr zu essen gab
wir saßen dabei draußen im garten und
genossen das schöne spätsommerwetter
auch wenn meine mutter vieles vergessen
hatte aber der geschmack der frischen
mirabellen und das gefühl von
leichtigkeit blieb ihr erhalten
meine mutter war glücklich wenig später
erkrankte meine mutter in einer corona
infektion
sie wurde innerhalb des seniorenheims
auf eine isolierstation verlegt und
besucher waren leider nicht mehr möglich
der arzt informiert uns regelmäßig über
ihren aktuellen gesundheitszustand und
vier fieberten und banken zu hause mit
konnten aber nichts tun
nach wenigen tagen verschlechterte sich
ihr zustand und sie verstarb leider
konnte keines ihrer vier kinder auf
diesen letzten auf diesem letzten weg
begleiten
das war für uns alle sehr traurig am
zweiten oktober wurde meine mutter in
einem urwald und einem schönen baum
beigesetzt
in der natur ganz so wie sie sich vor
ihrem tod wünschte der black ops wird
nun als letzter der angehörigen eine
kerze abstellen in der mitte des raums
damit sind dann alle zehn kerzen
abgestellt so weit auch stephan harbarth
der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes der ihn
begleiten wird seine kerze abgestellt
hat
nach einem kurzen moment der stille des
innehaltens werden gleich bilder von
verstorbenen aus allen teilen
deutschlands gezeigt musikalisch
untermalt vom adagio for strings von
samuel barber diese menschen stehen
stellvertretend für die menschen der
pandemie von denen sich die angehörigen
oft nur schwer oder gar nicht
verabschieden konnten sie geben den
schicksalen hinter den zahlen ein
gesicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem adagio for strings von samuel
barber folgt nun ein stilles gedenken
anschließend hören wie die europa sowie
die nationalhymne gespielt von musikern
des konzerthausorchesters berlin unter
leitung von zajac osaka
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja das war die zentrale gedenkfeier für
die verstorbenen während der korona
pandemie
bei mir ist noch mal der ratsvorsitzende
der evangelischen kirche hier in
deutschland herr bedford strohm mehr
welche aussagen welche momente sind
ihnen ganz besonders in erinnerung
geblieben
aber es war ein sehr berührender
gedenkakt natürlich die reden der
betroffenen die einfach die ganz
unterschiedlichen fälle geschildert
haben und auch die trauer uns glaube ich
allen ins herz gegeben haben eine starke
eine mitfühlt rede des bundespräsidenten
und dann am ende der der aufruf von frau
schädel aus passau halten sie durch das
wird mir besonders in erinnerung bleiben
dass wir wissen wir müssen jetzt uns an
die regeln halten damit nicht noch mehr
menschen sterben
und welches signal glauben sie geht
jetzt von dieser gedenkveranstaltung aus
ich glaube das ist ein ganz wichtiger
tag für deutschland denn da wo wir
selber nicht die erfahrungen mit
menschen haben werden wir jetzt an ganz
konkrete menschen denken wenn wir die
zahlen der toten im fernsehen oder im
radio hören
und deswegen haben die toten heute ein
gesicht bekommen das wird uns im herzen
bleiben
vielen dank der bedford strohm ja das
war es von uns aus berlin ein moment des
innehaltens sollte die gedenkfeier heute
sein und ein zeichen der anteilnahme mit
dem signal man ist eben nicht alleine
auch wenn einsamkeit das traurige
kennzeichen dieser pandemie ist auf
wiedersehen